technology and original human species
can exist
in a peaceful way
as long as the people that know how to
make robots aren't using their robots to
control the humans
Lex
definitely something you have to be
concerned about as we become more
technologically savvy that my friend is
why engineering isn't everything that
you have to desperately study the
lessons of history in Nazi Germany
science was used to create atrocities
engineering the same engineering could
be a tool of War we are still in the
Holocaust
uh a friend a Jewish friend of mine said
come go visit the Holocaust Museum and
my response was let's visit our
Holocaust Museum Planned Parenthood
with all due respect I grew up in the
Soviet Union
I'm Jewish
parts of my family perished in the in
the Holocaust of Nazi Germany I have to
push back that there is a difference
of the atrocities at that scale at that
time on an entire piece I was going to
say the number that's the difference
it's not the number because 6 million
will also
African Americans are actually Jew also
the Lost tribe of Israel is back on that
too okay so well everyone came from
Africa I am African I'm basically
African-American we're brothers and
we're both Jew and we're brothers so
we're human six million people died in
the Holocaust over 20 million have died
by the hands of abortion and the media
promotes the my body my choice which is
actually still a promotion for Planned
Parenthood
fifty percent of black deaths
a year is actually abortion it's not
it's not the cop with the knee it's not
black on black violence and gang
violence not heart attacks it's actually
abortion the most dangerous place for a
black person in America is in their
mother's stomach
this 900 to a million abortions in the
United States a year
I hear you
but there's something about
the rape the torture the murder of
children women men the complete complete
humiliation and just the suffering that
was endured during World War II that's
what we deal with on our TVs right now
with black people
Soros would use black trauma economy for
to win an election
and what I love is having a healthy
conversation and as opposed to the
certain things you know boom this drops
people gonna have [ __ ] hats on Boom
this drops is gonna be you know black
people and white people with signs boom
this drops so hey China
hey left agenda hey what we're gonna do
is say that our species can have a
healthy conversation D it's can I just
Linger on this because when you say
Jewish media
it there's a echo of a pain that people
feel that reminds me you're saying it's
redundant right
huh no I'm not saying it's redundant I'm
saying it's redundant you're saying it's
redundant it's already not saying it's
something that you're I'm saying that
it's something that Joseph gerbil's the
propaganda minister of Nazi Germany said
I'm saying it's been said so many times
in order to murder and torture
Jewish people that it just Rings wrong
and that's just like the N word when
spoken by people that have the same skin
color as me it reminds people of a very
dark time I know if if Jewish people
would accept that I'm Jew then they
would see what I'm saying in a different
way they would hear it in a different
way but see the people you saying you're
Jewish that no I'm Jew not Jewish Jewish
means like that of a Jew I'm saying I'm
Jew you're Jew blood of Christ
right but that are you
um
are you a follower of the philosophy of
the Black Hebrew Israelites
because that's where the idea comes from
not all of those folks are extremists
but some are extremists I'm a follower
of the idea I have a vague idea that all
people came from Africa
but what I wanted to do not okay
now I could Andy Kaufman this about
seven more minutes and then tell you
what it is
let's count seven minutes no I did this
to do a spoiler alert sure spoiler
what's the first thing I said at the
beginning
we're talking about engineering and
humans and then what did I say we
shouldn't focus on Race not just that
I said they shouldn't teach this in
school
history the history because what they do
what schools are doing is exactly what
the CIA does with Pixar films and Disney
films they make Bambi's mom die in the
beginning right and off that pain comes
a purchase of ice cream off that pain
comes I need some more toys off that
pain comes I need a bigger house off
that pain comes I need more girls than
my wife off that pain comes so they put
that pain in to make us uh now where the
Orphans of capitalism to make us be
consumers and we need to be a community
not just consumers so I could have went
another seven minutes by being a person
who presents himself in a way that says
well I don't have to feel your pain
because I also have pain too that's not
being recognized and in every interview
when I say well why do I get to the
point of putting up the tweet
uh no one wants to understand why I got
to that point right pain you had pain
yeah but no one in your heart but the
let's say this undoubtedly Jewish people
have a lot of movies about
that pain and black people have a lot of
movies about the pain of slavery right
it's almost impossible to find a movie
about Mansa Musa when you go to the
African history museum in Washington DC
it doesn't start with the idea of
Africans being Kings it starts with the
idea of Africans being slaves but here's
another interesting point about this
this was said to me one time and it
stuck with me as a family member of mine
with Africans how many times you've
heard like a rapper or you know talk
about we were Kings
that's incorrect
if we're Jew
if we're Jew and since we are we weren't
the Kings we were the slaves that Moses
freed
Africans have always said we've heard
you've listened to rap music and hear
black people say we Kings we blood of
the Pharaohs
and
if we are Jew
then we were
we were the people that Moses freed
and when we talk about have you heard
black people talk about 400 years of
slavery all right that is in rep and
we're having this history lesson right
and my history doesn't matter you're
exploring ancient history and drawing
deep wisdom from it and at the same time
saying we need to forget all of it
we need to put that behind us absolutely
we need to forget it and we need to move
forward there's so much wisdom to draw
from history even the 20th century look
at this communism
without the lessons the history of the
20th century communism sounds like a
great idea
except that some of the worst atrocities
conducted by Stalin and Mao that killed
50 hundred plus million people not just
killed tortured starvation where people
the uh cannibalism they hate each other
they ate their children there's there's
just dark people people should read some
books on this on the hall and a more see
the 1930s with that lesson we would and
now it's I don't mean more popular
Marxism and communism I'm not
disagreeing that that happened I'm
disagreeing that
we need to harp on the things that
happen because the truth is I'm given a
fact 50 today of
let's say you don't call black people
Jew right black people's death today is
abortion today right now like that it's
not racism that's too wide of a term
it's genocide and population control
that black people are in today in
America that is promoted by the music
and the media that black people make
that Jewish record labels get paid off
of or media companies uh regular labels
Media Company also so let's give it a
wider you know I agree with Martin
Luther King
I have a dream too that one day you
would not be judged by the color of your
skin
or your race black or Jew but by the
content in your character all the
[ __ ] that [ __ ] you over in the
music industry [ __ ]
artists over in the music industry are
individuals they're not Jews can you can
you say they are they are Jewish
it doesn't they're human with
opportunities
and they took those opportunities I
don't care if they're Jewish you feel
like I should release that pain and
separate it
yes okay so if that if okay so if you're
saying I should release that pain and
separate it then I'm telling you you
should release your pain and separate it
and we could get to this the list of how
you are being with engineering
opportunities that's 100 I see what
you're doing that exactly you're doing
the pain I'm gonna let it go engineering
challenges I get it